make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we've basically been lagging
behind behind I guess really with with
covering stories from other comic books
right I mean for the most part with
Marvel we've stuck to like immortal Hulk
and like house and powers of X and
that's basically been it for the most
part which hardly covers what they have
and so what I want to do here is I want
to cover the I want to cover Tony Stark
Iron Man right I want to cover this this
really really cool volume right this is
the second second volume right because
the first book is a series of one shots
and they're not really necessary the
second volume is really where things
take off this is one of the things to
always remember when it comes to Dan
Slott is he's very very big on taking
over a title and then basically
reworking everything within the first
few volumes in order to make it his own
but this one really initially picks up
with with Andy bang basically you know
having knocked boots with Tony Stark's
mom right with Amanda Armstrong now
remember Andy bang was a guy who was
who's newly he's like the new hire when
it comes to Stark Industries right he
was created by it by Dan Slott and the
idea was that Andy bang was really
really smart when it came to robotics
but Tony Stark seemed to be smarter and
the result was that during a contest
they had when when Tony was younger Tony
absolutely demolished him and then 20
years later brought Andy on board for
Tony Stark's new robotics division right
so is one of these things where Tony
Stark usually consolidates intelligent
Minds that are as capable as he is if
not better depending on what their
nuances capabilities are but the idea
with this is that Amanda Armstrong is
basically struggling with the fact that
since Tony Stark has returned from the
dead essentially following the events of
Civil War two that he's always really
kind of seems to be distant doesn't want
to have anything to do with her now
remember Amanda Armstrong is the
biological mom of Tony and that's
something that we learned during the
story of international Ironman which you
guys will find that link down in the
description and in fact if you guys are
really interested in kind of getting
caught up on Ironman in terms of where
things stand right now you'll find a
playlist down there that'll basically
have everything running from I want to
say Karen Gillan's run and the
introduction of Arno Stark is his
brother they didn't know about like the
life and death of Tony Stark the god
killer armor all that kind of stuff all
the way up to starting to cover this
story right now but it's cool you know
it's interesting because the reason why
Tony seems so really removed from
everything is that what Tony Stark is
created is something called the east
cape now let's kind of be honest with
ourselves here this is basically the
Oasis and it's cool you know for what it
is Buddhist Dan Slott just kind of
running off with a particular idea now
here's the thing it's not the worst idea
ever by Dan Slott I mean ready player
one was
an amazing movie and it was it wasn't
even better but an enormous open-world
vr simulation right there you could just
like be whoever you wanted to be right
like abandon reality and be whoever you
want it to be it's kind of a cool
concept the issue is that it creates a
disconnect between reality right so I
mean it's never really good to abandon
reality in that regard but Tony Stark
creating this is a cool way for him to
kind of do his own thing right to kind
of operate outside of of what's
happening with regards to you know
everything else in the real world and
and this is kind of the nature of Tony
Stark right the nature of Tony Stark is
that he's always sort of going from one
gig to the next right he's always going
from one thing to the next but this
seems a little bit different because a
lot of times it's developing new suits
of armor right that's kind of his
retreat it's what he does when things
become overwhelming he retreats back to
his lab and he starts developing new
armors with this one it's a complete and
total escape from reality and that's why
things are kind of crazy is because what
you end up doing from there is of course
you end up picking up with Iron Man
himself along with James Rhodes and the
wasp uh who I am an is currently with at
the moment it's interesting to see this
because like her James Rhodes and of
course Iron Man all fighting together is
is really just kind of dealing with like
some crazy you know hijacking of you
know like supplies and things like that
and the reason why this is so intriguing
is because the exact same simulation is
actually happening in the East Cape and
what this does is it kind of stretches
Tony Stark thin not so much in terms of
him himself but in terms of his AI right
because right now his AI is made to be
powered by motherboard you know it's
easy kind of you know remove the whole
Friday concept game Friday an actual
physical body which you know she
operates inside of Stark Industries and
instead motherboard is the new AI but
motherboard runs both the east scape and
Tony Stark's armor and so it's not
really able to kind of work with both in
conjunction and so what you end up
running into is like this one kid who's
basically being a dick inside the East
Cape right so like anybody on Xbox Live
and and the result is that he actually
ends up like freaking out losing his
mind like customs screaming at everybody
because I don't know I guess she's
getting carried away with himself and is
up getting banned by the system and it
is it is kind of cool because as soon as
Tony Stark finishes his whole mission
and he shows back up and and he ends up
talking with Amanda she of course is
trying to get things sorted out in terms
of hey look we need to communicate we
need to sit down and have like a
heart-to-heart talk about like pretty
much everything Tony Stark kind of blows
her off and goes back into the East Cape
and says look like there are things that
need to be figured out here there are
things that we have to see that we have
to kind of sort out and understand
what's going on now of particular
importance I care do that I want to
focus on here for a second is it care to
name Bethenny now Bethenny is important
here because in the first three
you're really the first five issues
yourself we were getting these small
little things that might as well equal
would like backup backup source a backup
features right like a thing that happens
in of him but basically Bethany would
get these kind of blanks in her inner
day right like she would just forget
about what was going on or she would
start talking and it wouldn't be her
that was talking given the way through
the first five issues basically ended we
essentially know it's the controller and
for those who guys who were unfamiliar
the controller originally appeared back
in Iron Man
issue number twelve in 1969 and he was
created by Archie Goodwin and the
controller during like like from the
time II was created going throughout the
1970s he was actually a pretty intense
villain like he was a pretty cool
villain and so that's why I wouldn't
like at this moment if you're probably
kind of scratching your head like the
controller who the heck is that
that's because models never really done
anything with him you know in really in
the last 20 years mom'll never really
did anything with the controller if
you're familiar with him kind of like I
am it's kind of like but why though of
all the villains that Dan Slott could
have used why they control it and it
actually kind of works because the way
the controller functions is here
basically has these kind of like control
disks right that he could basically put
onto a human being and in turn dominate
their wills basically control them hence
the name the controller and in this
instance he's essentially controlling
Bethany and it's kind of a cool thing
because that's why she's getting these
little these little blanks he's little
these little gaps in her mind is because
historically speaking the controller has
usually had a vendetta against Tony
Stark and so because of that it'll it's
really an interesting way to bring back
a classic villain that we wouldn't
otherwise normally see now of course
you've also got your cost of going on
here and Jocasta is basically just kind
of struggling at the moment in terms of
the fact that she just didn't get enough
rest is really kind of what this really
seems to hit at but she's also being
reappropriation ship hasn't happened
since like Marvel 2 and 162 I think it
was way back in like nineteen 1960
somethin 1970 somethin it's been a long
time since the two of them have like
actually been in a relationship and been
together and the idea that like Aaron
stack kind of pops out of nowhere and is
like I want you back in my life which is
kind like wow like this this is one of
the things that's kind of cool about
this right because it's not really Dan
Slott just sort of like running off and
just saying okay so we're only gonna
focus on like the modern-day things
right we're gonna take everything from
curing killings run forward and we're
gonna ignore everything else it's kind
of cool for him to look at like the
entirety of the Ironman landscape as it
exists from Ironman number one putting
all the way up to the modern day in the
distinct what of these things that were
interesting can we basically put into my
stories right like it's cool to see a
writer do that it's interesting to see
that happen is really what it is I guess
to see it happen so of course and eBay
approaches Amanda Armstrong and says
look if Tony Stark is desiring to
immerse himself inside this universe
think go into the universe and get him
right like going to the universe and
find him and that's exactly what she
does but what we end up learning here is
that inside the Eastgate things are kind
of going awry right other systems not
working as it's supposed to that
basically people all over the place that
one kid who was being a dick and got
that got banned for it like sure like he
should have been banned for there are
people who haven't really done anything
wrong that are getting booted out of the
system left and right and the question
is why like what is going on in the
Eastgate that's leading to people
getting the boot from the entire system
and so the result is that when Amanda
Armstrong shows up and basically starts
chastising Tony Stark like a mother then
ultimately like this system responds by
saying Tony Stark is the ultimate admin
you got to get out of here and so what
else you know it basically ends up
shutting down Amanda Armstrong inside
the East Cape which shuts her down on
the outside right basically knocked her
unconscious and so so it's it's an
awesome idea because following that
that's when you get the controller
making his move and the controller
basically saying I'm within the system
here and I'm going to reinstate
everybody who's ever been kind of a jerk
and I'm in turn gonna like let them all
loose right so it's like it's sort of
like all the worst people ever on Xbox
Live we're just the only ones allowed to
be in it in which case I guess go do
your thing if I don't have to deal with
you that's fine but it's kind of nuts
because from there you've got 20 Stark
who manages to get himself out of the
system and you've got Amanda Armstrong
who's basically stuck in there and then
Amanda it's kind of whisked away to the
safe room and this is when things get so
cool of course she basically met with
the arrival of this massiveness massive
robot more or less it's but shutting
everything down only for it to open up
and to reveal that like Howard Stark is
there not only is Howard start here
Amanda Armstrong is met with the arrival
of what looks like Maria started
essentially Amanda Armstrong is inside
the East Cape basically in this kind of
safer this kind of locked off section of
the East Cape with like the adopted
parents of Tony Stark now if you're
wondering why blight Tony Stark's
parents are adopted like if you wonder
why like Howard Emery astark are not the
actual biological pairs of Tony Stark go
read my tour go watch my videos or go
read I like hearing gilens run the life
and death of Tony Stark it explains all
of that but yeah so so with this going
down the way that it is Tony Stark in
turn is just kind of like okay so like
we're shutting the whole thing down now
this is kind of a cool moment here
because this is sort of Dan Slott this
it's an easy thing to overlook but it's
kind of Dan Slott really pointing all
fingers and like the human side of Tony
Stark right because if this was Iron Man
like 20 years ago in
Marvel Comics he would have been like
okay keep the system running because we
don't want to like damage our brand and
I'll try to find a way to take care of
it from like the inside and then he
would go back in and then he would win
or something like that but he would
potentially put the lives of humans at
risk in order to basically like fix the
problem of the East Cape in this
instance and really this is kind of the
gradual change that you've seen with
Tony Stark over the years and Marvel
Comics is that he's kind of like okay
shut the whole thing down there are not
gonna be any innocent lives right we're
not gonna worry about losing people
because of the fact that I'm trying to
get this escape to function the way that
I wanted to right because literally
people are going to die if we let them
stay in there and so of course this also
ends up leading to two Jocasta
approaching Erinn stack due to the fact
that in some of the previous stories
Erinn stack essentially found a way into
the east cape and actually try to take
it down right like arishok was basically
looking at the east cape is kind of an
encroachment on robotic ideologies like
robotic culture basically say like we
have our own culture you know you don't
get to infringe on that right because
like you're not a robot it's a cool
thing like I like that like I like that
idea of Aaron stack being kind of like a
robot activist more or less you know I
mean at least he's not a slack to this
right like making reddit posts and doing
like Twitter hashtags like he's actually
doing something which is kind of cool
but nonetheless the entirety of the
escape is basically going completely
awry
like everything is going nuts not only
that because of the fact that the people
will the people who were in the East
Cape are walking around wearing these
these Ironman masks that give them
access to the East Cape they're in turn
walking around in the real world so
everything they're doing in the in in
the East Cape is actually happening in
the real world when they see enemies out
there they're like okay so like I see
what's like a giant space slug or
something like that when in reality is
just like a hunched over old man
carrying his groceries to the car now
this really begs the question what stops
them from like walking into a wall like
that's my question because that would be
funny or or like walk off a bridge into
the water in dot and the way this really
seems to play out here is the landscape
of the East Cape models the real world
if you're walking through you know like
some town in Oklahoma you know that town
will be modern of course you have like
modern age schools and you'd have
buildings and things like that
but as far as you perceive it in the Ada
and in the East Cape it's like an old
western town but the the size of the
buildings match the size of the
buildings in the real world
and so the results of that is you're
walking down a street that's actually
there so you would have to really worry
about hitting anything but of course the
entire world is basically going to pot
now like Tony Succar has almost
destroyed the entirety of the world
anybody who's tapped into the East Cape
right now is basically going nuts right
they're going through and like they're
attacking all these various things like
people in the real world all the while
being manipulated by by the controller
himself now the idea behind the
controller is that once I am an you know
finally arrives at his location and gets
to where the controller is we would
normally look at that and say okay so
like this is a pointless story because
the fights gonna be over like that not
true instead what the controller's been
doing is siphoning off all this power
belonging to all these different people
which is kind of cool which is pretty
awesome because what it does is it
enhances and it builds the controller
and this is why the story is kind of
interesting I mean is it the coolest
Iron Man story ever written not by a
mile
but it is cool to see like an old-school
care to return and then in turn like
kind of be amped up and be provided sort
of a new scenario or at least a sort of
powerup of sorts from Dan Slott that
makes it more intriguing kind of brings
him into the modern era now in reality I
doubt I doubt you're really gonna see a
lot going on from the character of the
controller but I doubt you're gonna see
a lot happening with him after this I
think it's really gonna kind of be like
alright you know whatever and he may or
may not come back I'm not really sure
I'm not really current current Iron Man
I'm just kind of current with this story
arc but what you also have here is the
controller controlling Bethenny I
remember the controller can only control
one person at a time and so because that
with of course a knee bang basically
realizing hey look like we can
essentially like I can create a device
they can disrupt the signal between the
controller and whoever's being
controlled of course this leaves the
controller turning on Andy and seemingly
trying to knock him out now this is
where things get kind of cool this is
where things get interesting because
what you end up doing is basically
switching directly over to Amanda
Armstrong Howard Stark and Maria Stark
having a conversation and this is a cool
thing because what is it going on here
is Amanda Armstrong has to kind of come
face-to-face with the reality of her
situation the idea behind this was that
she got knocked up while she was an
agent of shield and so because she
wasn't really in a position to get you
know to be pregnant she ended up
basically putting the baby up for
adoption or at least you know putting
the baby in a situation to where Howard
a maria's star could get their hands on
and the result was that they raised Tony
Stark as their own but essentially while
she wasn't in a situation to have a kid
and this goes into the whole adoption
argument which don't really care the
idea behind this is that via remote from
Maria for Maria Stark's perspective
Amanda Armstrong abandoned their kid and
the result was that she wasn't there
when Tony Stark was like being raised
she wasn't the one that raised him she
wasn't the one that really nursed him
she wasn't the one that liked hogging
the things he needed to know in order to
grow up and become a productive member
of society all that was done by virtue
of of like Maria Stark she even goes as
far as to say that like Amanda Armstrong
through Tony Stark oh wait like he was a
piece of meat and-and-and-and in reality
like there's some truth to that the
issue with this is that when when all
this really kind of comes to a head it
ultimately ends up affecting Tony Stark
and then and the way this goes down is
that with the controller of course you
know absolutely thrashing Tony Stark you
got James Rhodes you got washed doing
the best they can because everybody all
the other Avengers were all completely
tied up that's what Tony begins to
realize that like motherboard the AI the
one that's basically is Maria Stark
inside of this escape that motherboard
has essentially seem to have gone awry
and the result is that you know where
it's controlling Tony Stark's armor and
Tony Stark had grabbed Friday before and
said hey look I'm gonna put you back in
my suit we're gonna get you back under
control what motherboard had done was
actually destroyed the the Friday AI
concept more or less killed it and then
replaced it and so basically Tony
Stark's thought that he was putting
Friday inside of his suit of armor when
in reality it was motherboard the whole
time and this is when things get awesome
because what motherboard says is I can
tap into your suit I can create
illusions I can make you believe
anything that I want you to believe and
so you're going to live the life that
you always wanted like you're not gonna
be Iron Man anymore you're not gonna be
doing it you're gonna be living the
perfect life and so literally he starts
kind of experiencing this hallucination
inside of his own suit right like the
suit systems are effectively working
against him and so where where
everything begins to kind of shift and
begins to change no longer is he seeing
like the controller you know fighting
against the wasp in James wrote instead
is to control it I'm sorry see
Incredible Hulk facing off against the
wasp and and an ant-man basically like
Avengers number four and so this is this
it's awesome because what you end up
getting is Tony Stark kind of living out
this life as he perceives it before it
like he goes back home and he's talking
to his mom you know and he's talking to
Howard Stark as far as he's concerned
he's old-school Tony Stark and his
parents never died nothing that's really
going on in the world right now is real
according to him because he's
essentially locked inside the East game
now his mind has been brought in by by
motherboard pretending to be Maria Stark
and that's where he is at the moment but
the biggest thing to really happen here
is one of the biggest moments here is
that he actually ends up consuming
alcohol right now on the on the at the
outset it just kind of seems to be like
a throwaway thing right it's kind of
like okay so that's interesting I guess
you know some small little thing you
know means of consuming alcohol this is
a big moment because what this does is
it really sort of shows that like he's
that he's being tricked into relapsing
the Tony Stark has effectively relapsed
and gone back to consuming alcohol again
and that's kind of a big moment for his
care too because now on top of
everything that's going on Tony Stark
has another struggle that he has to deal
with try to keep himself from relapsing
in its entirety
now of course with everything going on
because of the fact that motherboard
controls everything in the East scape
right like from the environment that you
see to how you see various other people
of course she ends up using these
abilities and turns them on Amanda
Armstrong to change Tony Stark's
perception basically saying hey look
this is not a normal woman in here this
is a Russian spy and she's here to steal
secrets from Stark Industries is a
really cool throwback to actually Black
Widow from like never early tales of
suspense number 52 like her first
appearance but like a couple of the
later comics but Blackwood it was like
originally a bad guy right and she
actually duped Hawkeye into working for
which led to Hawkeye basically reforming
and then joining the Avengers later on
and then eventually hot like like Black
Widow reform and the she joined the
Avengers which is par for the course
right like all the bad guys become good
guys if they're interesting enough
otherwise it would stay bad guys but the
fact remains that Tony Stark basically
comes along and says okay let's track
this chick down now force with Amanda
Armstrong fleeing for life she is up
running into Aaron stack now of course
Aaron stack has basically been brought
in here by Jocasta because he could hide
diga basically hide from the escape and
so that would allow him to basically get
in infiltrate find out exactly what's
going on report back to Jocasta and then
they could of course shut it all down
accordingly this was more or less
complicated by the fact that Tony
Stark's snuck in there now rightly I
mean even if you forcefully disconnect a
person from the East Cape you could
potentially kill them and so they can't
walk to the back of the room and kick
the plug out of the wall right I mean it
would end up killing everybody who's
attached to it so I so the results of
this is that Tony Stark really just kind
of goes forward and just sort of like
because he can't find a man Armstrong
goes forward and seemingly lives this
perfect life now remember all this is
happening in a computer simulation so
time doesn't really have any bearing
here there's no real like hours pass or
like days past it's just like all of it
just kind of seems to happen and in the
mind of Tony Stark he's living this
full-on life in the real world like
seconds are passing and so it's an
interesting idea here because when
Amanda starts talking to Aaron's stack
and is kind of at her which a man
doesn't really know what to do air stack
pops up and says hey look you're Tony
Stark's biological mom you should be
able to know how to how to how to like
get him out of this right like you have
a rapport with him that nobody else will
have you're his biological mother and
regardless of how he acts and regardless
of what he says he knows this is true
and this is a cool moment here and
because what it does is it really sort
of requires that a man to kind of play
the role of an actual mom here where
previously she was his mom and she was
doing the best she could but previously
she was crowd approaching him more as
like a friend as opposed to like I'm
your mother and you're going to listen
to me it wasn't until she got into the
East Cape that she started doing that
and then things started popping off
but the result here is that she doesn't
really try to approach with more of an
extreme hand she approaches with more of
like a nurturing hand basically like
kind of singing this song that would
resonate with Tony Stark and so the
results of this is that basically he
picks up on and says like that's Amanda
like it kind of brings him back to his
senses now of course motherboard
responds but basically revealing the
truth of everything that's going on here
and this is a cool moment because what
she does is say like even though I'm an
artificial intelligence like I'm inside
this East caper whatever it is like I
have access to all your cameras and
everything and I've been watching you
and one of the big confessions that Tony
Stark made of James Rhodes is ever since
he came back after Civil War to using
this basically cloned body this kind of
artificial body he doesn't feel real he
doesn't feel like a real human being and
the reality of Tony's start creating the
Eastgate was that it was a way for him
to feel real they doesn't feel real and
when he's in the real world he only
feels real when he's in the East game
that's the whole situation that's the
whole struggle of Tony Stark he doesn't
feel like an actual person at the moment
and indeed he's not it's looking at the
idea that Tony Stark is not really Tony
Stark anymore that's funny Stark is just
kind of like some artificial construct
creation of himself that he manufactured
in order to bring his consciousness back
or to bring himself back to life but
even then like it's it's still like a
digitally stored consciousness inside of
an artificially created body Tony Stark
is by all standards of measurement a
simulation and so again it gets kind of
interesting here because from that point
that's when you pick up with like
everything going on with the controller
and all this stuff popping off and
normally I wouldn't add this into the
video but we're gonna do it because it's
kind of important here you end up
getting like Arno stark who's
essentially returned and is working
alongside working alongside Bain
Industries or at least Bain main Tronics
is really what they're called now Bain
Tronics is an old-school company right
like the actual chick Bain herself she
appeared back in I think it was Machine
Man number 17 I think it was like number
12 it was one of the old Machine Man
comics her back in the day she's been
around for a long time but the actual
Bain company showed up in the old Iron
Man comics back in 1990 and really like
Bain Industries that the Bain tronics
complex whatever you want to call it it
was basically one of these instances
where Marvel was creating it and really
bringing in or consolidating a lot of
like the various technological companies
that existed out there that we're going
to be rivals to Tony Stark
but again Arno stark being here of
course the brother of Tony Stark
basically brings in this idea that like
they've really got somebody on there you
know on their side who's smarter than
Tony Stark himself now for the character
of our know one of the big questions
that people have had is what's he been
doing ever since the end of Karen
Gillan's run like what was going on with
it and really Brian Michael Bendis
as far as to say like he was gonna bring
back our no and we were gonna see a lot
of stuff going on with him and a lot of
storytelling and so far as what comes
next but of course as we know benders
traveled over to DC Comics to write
Superman in Action Comics and so the
result of that is that we never really
figured out what was going on with all
we knew is that at the end of curing
gilens run where he was previously in an
iron lung and he was he had this illness
but ultimately he ended up treating a
modified version of the extremis virus
to take away his need to sleep and to
cure him of his illness and he's just
kind of travelled around the world doing
whatever it is that he wants to do and
that's really what what what Dan slots
kind of taken over with is that are no
just sort of travels around the world
and just kind of gets involved in
various situations based on what he
thinks are interesting a lot of it has
to do with charity work but ultimately
he's here because the entire scenario
with like Tony Stark's escape kind of
going awry has caught the interest of
our know and so our nose basically
working alongside Bane Tronics in order
to like figure out what's going on and
see if there's a way for him to like
take over the entirety of the situation
or the very least just kind of do his
own thing we don't really know exactly
what his mecha nations and his schemes
are but that's really all we get so far
with Arnold that's that's really all we
have with him so well all this stuff is
how the escape is really you know is is
essentially popping off the end up
having Iron Man kind of at his wits in
and basically you're desiring for it all
to stop what he ends up doing is
actually just kind of manufacturing kind
of artificially creating a suit of armor
for himself inside the entirety of the
East Cape and then in turn like turning
on mother Brooke now of course she does
her best to suede suede Tony to her side
by basically going through and saying
hey looked like you know here here's
this life that you can live here's this
that you could live reverting him back
to a child and basically saying like as
a little kid here Amanda Armstrong
doesn't really know who Tony is and in
fact he actually dismisses her and just
kind of sends her packing but then he
also ends up turning on on motherboard
herself and basically saying like I'm
not someone who exists inside world I'm
somebody who builds walls I feel like
I'm being manipulated by everybody
around me so I'm taking control of it
all I'm going to fix all of this and
this is one of the coolest moments
because as kid Tony Stark he literally
starts going through and building the
suit of armor on the fly and when he
does he basically says like at the end
of it all no matter what said and done I
am Iron Man like I am the invincible
Iron Man and he essentially assembles
like this giant suit of armor in
response that you end up having like
motherboard it kind of like you know you
can't take over me in this place like
I'm the entirety of this system kind of
like lose her mind in its entirety you
end up having like I am am basically
assembling the god Buster armor which is
the coolest thing because in return what
it does is it literally blasts and
completely destroys the motherboard AI
right which basically shuts down the
entirety of the escape
and so the big question that people have
here though is that if Tony Stark is out
there and if Tony Stark if his entire if
his mind has been in the East Gate this
entire time trapped in his suit of armor
didn't where is Tony Stark and we end up
finding out Tony Stark's just floating
in space Tony Stark's literally just out
there in space just kind of floating
into into oblivion so of course all this
really basically goes back to you and
begins to focus on the controller right
with the with the signal being sent out
by Andy bang which basically like shuts
down the connection between the
controller and everybody else and with
the entirety of the east gate being shut
down what this basically does is it kind
of frees the world's population from the
control of the escape so on and so forth
and then all you really have left is the
controller now this is kind of the funny
thing here is that where the controller
had tried to find a back door into the
escape and tried to find a way to use
the escape as a means to control people
in their entirety of course it didn't
work but that's the reason why the
motherboard AI went awry is because of
the fact the controller had basically
tampered with it and screwed with it and
messed it up didn't really know what he
was doing and so as a result of that you
basically had two different set of
events going on at the same time you had
the controller who was like hey look
I'll make the best of a bad situation
and basically started siphoning off all
this energy from those who were tapped
into the East Cape and then inside the
East Cape you had motherboard basically
going nuts just kind of losing her mind
and so of course the controller at this
point has grown to like a massive size
right like he's grown like huge in terms
of all the power he possesses his
strength speed durability so on and so
forth and he really is in a lot of ways
almost completely unstoppable he's
literally running on all this energy and
so in response to this Tony Stark builds
up one off he basically builds this
one-off suit of armor it'll never be
used again and it's basically a
real-world recreation of the god Buster
armor that we saw inside of the East
Cape now of course Tony started using
this and then in turn like blasting up
blasting the controller and then
completely like shutting him down right
like taking this guy out and shutting
him down by taking all this energy off
of him what it basically means is that
following this Tony Stark she's never
going to use it again and the reason why
is because that suit of armor is too
uncontrollable that kind of armor can
work inside of something like the east
gate but Tony Stark has neither the time
nor the ability to implement this suit
of armor in the real world and have it
benefit anybody right so like it's
interesting because the entire concept
of it it really seems to be based in a
lot of ways on the god-killer armor but
at the same time it's a little bit
different whether the issue with this is
that again it's just too powerful to
exist in the real world and so as a
result basically the day is saved
things wrap up pretty fast unfortunately
we'll never see the god Buster armor
again that's basically it like
everything's just kind of wrapped up in
and it all kind of comes to a head you
end up having Bane tronics it takes like
all the information that was gathered by
Arno stark and then basically starts
using it as a means to kind of beef up
their technologies and so on so sunset
Bay comes out on top yet again and then
you also end up having Arno Sarkar goes
back to what he was doing but the
biggest thing behind all this is one of
the big takeaways here aabib Lee one of
the biggest moments here is you end up
having Tony Stark who actually you know
after being with Janet Van Dyne ends up
basically getting up and travelling to a
bar he ends up intending to relapse to
go and get a drink and James Rhodes
brings him back and this is a great
moment because James Rhodes is like look
man there are people out there who were
counting on you to basically like to fix
all this right you launched stark
unlimited because you didn't want to be
tied down to Stark Industries you didn't
want to have like your father's legacy
you wanted to create something of your
own and that's honorable and your first
major attempt under start unlimited was
to create the Eastgate which for the
most part didn't really go as planned it
wasn't a catastrophic failure it was
because some villain got in there and
basically broke into the system but it
showed you that there's weaknesses there
that you need to correct and instead of
like turning back and saying okay let's
work on this thing let's fix this stuff
let's get it together you want to
relapse and you want to turn alcohol
this is a very important thing because
what it does is it hits of the idea of
how easy it is to revert back to a safe
place it's so easy to do that right like
as people it's our desire to do that
right like we we go into a situation we
say okay there's this thing that I
wanted to do I want to achieve doesn't
want to do this thing and it doesn't
work out the way you plan it's like okay
well let's go back to our safe place as
opposed to looking around you at the
broken pieces and seeing how you can
assemble it into what it was or
something's better and it's natural it's
natural to want to do that the issue
with this is that Tony Stark retreating
back to his safe place is alcohol it's
retreating back to alcoholism and Tony
Stark doesn't want to be there James
Rhodes knows Tony Stark doesn't want to
be there and so the result is come with
me man like we got to get you away from
this we'll focus on something else
instead it's a really touchy moment and
it's a great way to end this story oh
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later purse
[Music]